Steve and twitch boss's mom shares a
heartbreaking message to her late son
on Wednesday news broke that twitch had
taken his own life the day after his
mother Connie spoke out on her Instagram
story thanking her family and friends
for all the love prayers and
encouragement I never take for granted
the moments that I can make my mom proud
fans of The Ellen Degeneres Show will
remember Connie's memorable appearances
alongside twitch he loves you so much
Helen I love him so much ashy Mourns
Connie wants people to know quote I see
all the messages texts posts and the
phone calls I can't use words right now
please know I will reach out when I can
please continue to keep us in prayer
Connie ends with a tribute to her son
Stephen Laurel your mother loves you to
Eternity and Beyond I have the sweetest
husband in the entire world last week
fans were devastated to learn twitch was
found dead at a motel in Encino
California less than a mile from his
home which he shared with wife Allison
holker and their two kids six-year-old
son Maddox and three-year-old daughter
ziya twitch is also dad to holger's 14
year old daughter Wesley from a previous
relationship we love the Full House and
also just to like family man like
honestly they're my favorite they're my
favorite people you know what I mean
twitch died of a self-inflicted gunshot
wound to the head and ETS learned he
left a note behind indicating that he
couldn't go on
wait holding up
et's also speaking with many of twitch's
friends from the tight-knit dancing
Community I've been an advocate for
mental health for a long time I've had
my own Journey with it I think many of
us have but to know that
someone that you would never ever expect
you would never have imagined we've
always crossed Paths of twitch and he is
was the nicest guy ever and Ellen
DeGeneres is sharing some of her
favorite moments with twitch over the
years that was my initial love for him
was we just bonded over learning to
dance together
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
twitch
then you know how much we we tell each
other that every day the comedian tells
fans that all she wants to do is
remember all the love and laughter they
had together is a life change and we're
all going through it that's Ellen
producer Andy lassner speaking to the
show staff in a clip that's gone viral
in the wake of twitch's death he
implored everyone to lean on each other
as twitch who had been Ellen's DJ since
2014 stands next to him and it's okay to
be sad and to reach out to each other
because nobody knows this exact
experience other than the people who
worked here the people
Warner Brothers who have taken care of
her we have all been through this and
and we went through it and we went
through it together you guys should be
proud that you suck it out you went
through it you got to see what we've
done for 19 years but keep each other
close
don't keep under pain talk to someone
[Music]